welcome to this video okay an Enzo maybe
a bogo know got a news 0 against Leone
ifugao on the only figured arrow from
Mexico yep from Mexico yeah do I get the
hoop no variation again no judgments he
is transporting to a sammich he 498 a
key booth the absolute main line of this
opening you like it's targeting
targeting c4
hmm five in exactly this moment
yeah that's a possibility
I can go nite a five-year then you can
play d 5 mm-hmm I really have forgotten
how this is played d 6 is also d6
sometimes I really don't know I have a
life i have forgotten how it is going
exactly played 9 a-5 d5 d6 is also
possible if I've a somewhat rare they
normally do now g3 for example ah ok now
i have room i was constantly looking for
this tactical trick there is a tactic m
and this is exactly the tactic him
exactly this Bishop d3 and then de 5pm I
was trying to remember why this this
exactly move order was a problem and I
have looked at this for the book this is
a game between Dutch Grand Master Jan
valla and Magnus Carlsen Carlton playing
black and he won this this pawn in this
fashion i am ok man took me a while but
i remembered it yeah because them yeah
yeah i have have uniform just a moment
though he's not threatening anything yet
yes come on let's play for now it's
clear that white has this long diagonal
now but the big point of blacks players
that later night to d6 will win the c-4
pond directly on I guess so I c4 is not
it's not it's not possible to save the
poem
yeah I see but ok I'm I really want to
make sure that I get the bishop on my
room resigns yeah yeah that's that's
early but the position is really falling
apart and took me while i was a bit
irritated by the by the move on I can
use this game to give a brief overview
of of this opening it's a pretty short
game anyway yeah after you for a
blackest is some force to play 98 this
is by far the best move the problem is
that if you don't do it there is Bishop
g5 coming setting up a very awkward pin
that you cannot really break with black
you simply don't have the dark squared
Bishop anymore only seven or anywhere to
break the pin so you need to avoid this
with 98 castles Bishop a6 of course
targeting the main weakness and whites
camp f4 and f5 this is an additional
point of the move Knight to e8 what
black wants to do he wants to set up
these blockades pawn on f5 and on c5 to
make sure that both the c1 Bishop is
biting on granite and the d3 Bishop
spriting on granite this means that
white absolutely must act quickly he
cannot in any way oh yeah they apply any
slow moves you need to be really really
quick now with your play what I actually
think what should do is to quickly open
open the sender and play something like
this or maybe Enzo 93 and this this type
of position is what why should try to
play here white has some chances yeah
chances are for example if he goes
something like this there is this idea
check getting a piece back leading to a
sharp tactical fighter
with about equal chances this is also
okay for black no worries what white
also can try can try the move d5 that's
also interesting the idea is that after
D 595 you play e5 now this is somewhat
similar to the game but only somewhat
there is one difference here the problem
is if black tries to now grab a pond
there is the move d6 and this is a very
interesting piece configuration with our
pond configuration is the spawns make
sure that the night only eight is never
moving anywhere c7 is covered you can
you can play something like this yeah
something like this is that same and we
can go here and here but that's it the
night is not ever going to return to the
Queen side and what has a very serious
compensation for the pawn however black
is not forced to take here black can
also play other moves mostly d6 which
leads to a very very sharp plane in the
game he started with e 5 and not with d5
and the difference is exactly what was
played d6 and he had probably white must
do something else d 5 is not really
working because of exactly what happened
this is a funny technical trick and
basically black is better now why do
only has some yeah he can hope for a
miracle with some some complicated yeah
attempts I'm trying to complicate
matters but there is really yeah really
no hope if black is playing correctly
and I think it was reasonably ok what I
did now c4 is falling and everything is
nicely coordinated the night on d6 is
the ideal swear and
White is very much weakened he resigned
early exactly here but there really is
not much to do if we consider night at
five for example to take en takes takes
takes takes yeah and this kind of
position is not really much fun Lex two
pawns up and test the better King
position yeah he just played him a bed a
bed terms on here but it also happened
to two Grand Master's before so it's um
yeah kind of a hidden hidden resource
that this is actually working I only
remembered it very lady I knew that if
I've had to draw back but took me about
to remember I knew that also it was this
Calvin game but not exactly the move
water right away right thanks for
watching